[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin ich wünsche Ihnen allen
einen schönen guten Abend den
sonntagsport später hat Norbert König im
Blick guten Abend und hier sind dann
unsere Themen
Rettung aus dem umkämpften Sudan die
ersten Ausländer sind in Sicherheit auch
die Evakuierungsaktion für die
verbliebenen deutschen läuft
Kompromiss im öffentlichen Dienst nach
monatelangem Ringen einigen sich
Arbeitgeber und Gewerkschaften im
Tarifstreit
und Jubel über den vierten Titel München
gewinnt die Meisterschaft in der
Deutschen Eishockey-Liga
[Musik]
mehr als 150 deutsche Staatsangehörige
hoffen in der von Kämpfen erschütterten
sudanesischen Hauptstadt cartoum darauf
sicher außer Landes zu kommen in diesem
Minuten läuft dann evakuierungseinsatz
der Bundeswehr die mit
militärtransportern und Fallschirmjägern
vor Ort ist seit einer Woche Toben im
Sudan schwere Kämpfe und seit Tagen
warten auch deutsche Bürger in der
Hauptstadt cartoum darauf in Sicherheit
gebracht zu werden jetzt ist die
Bundeswehr dort mit zwei
transportfliegern A400M hier vom
Verteidigungsministerium veröffentlichte
Bilder vergangene Aktion Ziel sei nun so
viele deutsche Staatsangehörige wie
möglich auszufliegen einige deutsche
schafften es womöglich schon raus
zusammen mit einer französischen
evakuierungsmission hier bei der Ankunft
in Dschibuti auch Großbritannien und die
USA haben Botschaft Personal und deren
Familien ausgeflogen und wir gehen jetzt
nach Kairo zu lügt was weiß man zum
Stand der deutschen Evakuierungsaktion
dass sie läuft weitere Details möchte
der Krisenstab verständlicherweise im
Moment nicht bekannt geben man wartet
darauf bis alle wirklich sicher das Land
verlassen hatten aber die beiden
Transportmaschinen sind wohl im Sudan
gelandet das kann man sagen die
Franzosen das haben wir eben gesehen
haben sogar schon Maschinen aus Sudan
heraus geschafft und nach Dschibuti eine
schwierige Operation es wurde zwar heute
um den Flughafen in cartoon nicht mehr
ganz so energisch gekämpft das hat doch
damit zu tun dass beide Kriegsparteien
zugesagt hatten sich zurückzuhalten um
die Ausländer evakuieren zu können
trotzdem wurde dieser Operation nicht am
internationalen Flughafen eratum sondern
außerhalb der Hauptstadt durchgeführt
dort sind die Maschinen gelandet man
kann zumindest sagen dass nach jetzigen
Stand kein Deutscher ähm irgendwie in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen wurde und ähm ob
die Operation damit abgeschlossen ist
das muss man warten denn es gibt auch
Konvois die sich ins 800 km
te Portugal aufgemacht haben
möglicherweise sind auch da noch
deutsche Staatsbürger dabei also die
Evakuierung ist heute noch nicht
endgültig abgeschlossen danke für die
aktuellen Informationen lügt nach Kairo
die Würfel sind gefallen seit dem späten
Nachmittag ist klar die Berliner
SPD-Mitglieder Stimmen für eine
Koalition mit der Hauptstadt CDU damit
ist CDU Wahlsieger Kai Wegner einen
Schritt weiter auf dem Weg zum neuen
Regierenden Bürgermeister von Berlin
eine Mehrheit von 54,3% habe sich mit ja
entschieden sagte die SPD
Landesvorsitzende gifhi von den mehr als
18.000 Parteimitgliedern hatten etwa
12.000 an der Befragung teilgenommen
im Tarif Streit des öffentlichen
Dienstes von Bund und Kommunen hat die
schlichterempfehlung den Durchbruch
gebracht arbeitgeber und Gewerkschaften
einigten sich in der vergangenen Nacht
und zwar auf folgendes ab Juni dieses
Jahres soll schrittweise bis Februar
2024 ein Inflationsausgleich von
insgesamt 3000 € bezahlt werden zum
ersten März 2024 gibt es erst einmal 200
€ mehr und dann ein Plus von 5,5 %
insgesamt mindestens 340 Euro Kathrin
Lindner
Krankenschwester Roberta marche tot auf
dem Weg von der Frühschicht nach Hause
für sie kommt die Erhöhung des Entgeltes
nächstes Jahr zu spät also ich bin echt
enttäuscht und frustriert ich arbeite in
der Pflege wir waren hier immer
systemrelevant in der ganzen Pandemie da
habe ich mir jetzt auch einfach mehr
erwartet zusammen mit der ziererin
Katharina doll organisierte sie in den
vergangenen Monaten arbeitsstreiks auch
sie hat sich mehr erhofft wir haben
einfach für mehr gekämpft wir wollten
500 €. wir wollten 10,5 % auf 12 Monate
und jetzt ist die Situation die dass auf
12 Monate eigentlich unsere Löhne
eingefroren werden die Gewerkschaften
wollten höhere Steigerungen in den
unteren Einkommensgruppen und eine
kürzere Laufzeit betonen aber jetzt das
ist die größte Tarifsteigerung in der
Nachkriegsgeschichte im öffentlichen
Dienst wir haben einen guten und fairen
Tarifabschluss für die mehr als 2,5
Millionen Beschäftigte für von Bund und
Kommunen gut getroffen Eichwalde bei
Berlin was kann sich die 6.000
Einwohnergemeinde dieses Jahr noch
leisten die Kämmerin heute beim Prüfen
ihrer Planungen neben höheren
Personalausgaben muss sie auch immer
mehr Aufgaben stemmen sei es die
Digitalisierung sei es geflüchteten sei
es aber auch die kita-bedarfe oder die
Grundschule und da ist wirklich wo ich
mir wünsche dass uns der Bund und das
Land tatsächlich mehr unterstützt bis
zum 12 Mai will die Gewerkschaft Verdi
ihre Mitglieder über die Einigung
abstimmen lassen
in der Ukraine da konzentrieren sich die
Kämpfe weiter auf das Gebiet Don jetzt
und da vor allem auf bachmut Russland
spricht aktuell von geländegewinnen in
der Stadt überprüfen lässt sich das
nicht eine Berichterstattung direkt von
dort unmöglich unsere Reporter daran hat
sich von Westen der Front genährt das
ukrainische Militär hat ihm Einblick in
einen Stützpunkt gewährt
wir fahren zu einer taktischen
panzereinheit stationiert nur wenige
Kilometer hinter der ukrainischen
kontaktlinie bei bachmund die Soldaten
schlafen in einfachen Datschen
durchschnittlich 2 bis 6 Kämpfer in
einem Haus so kann ein russischer
Artillerie Angriff nicht die ganze
Einheit treffen
wir sind nicht weit von der Frontlinie
entfernt es ist ein Ort von dem wir
schnell agieren können wenn der Befehl
für einen Einsatz kommt seit sechs
Monaten kämpft die Einheit schon um
bachmut
das ist nur natürlich wenn du Angst hast
es bedeutet Dein Körper hat diese
spezielle Situation adaptiert du darfst
nicht an schlimme Dinge denken mache
einfach deinen Job
zu den Panzern zu unserer waldgarage wie
Offizier Kosmos es nennt müssen wir zu
Fuß weitergehen der Boden sieht mir hier
ist noch vollkommen durchdrängt matschig
es ist nur immer noch nicht die beste
Zeit für eine große Offensive der
Stützpunkt der panzereinheit ihre
Aufgabe ist es denn Versorgungsweg ins
umkämpfte bachmut offen zu halten
wir sind die Lebensversicherung die
operieren in Frontabschnitten die unser
Oberkommando festlegt wir schlagen
feindliche Durchbrüche zurück und werden
die Russen nicht die Straße nach bachmut
abschneiden lassen
im Zuge der angekündigten großer von
Siever könnten weitere Aufgaben auf die
Einheit hinzukommen
fünf Tage nach einem Messerangriff in
einem Fitnessstudio in Duisburg sein
Tatverdächtiger festgenommen worden bei
dem Mann soll es sich um einen
26-jährigen Syrer Handeln ihm wird
vorgeworfen am Dienstagabend vier
Menschen mit einer Stichwaffe schwer
verletzt zu haben ein 21-jähriger
schwebt weiterhin in Lebensgefahr über
das Motiv des Angreifers ist noch nichts
bekannt
schwerer Unfall nahe Hannover an einem
Bahnübergang hat ein Regionalzug einen
Pkw erfasst der auf den Schienen stand
die drei Insassen alle Anfang 20 kamen
ums Leben nach ersten Erkenntnissen soll
das Auto trotz geschlossener
Halbschranke versucht haben die Gleise
zu überqueren der Zug schleifte des
Fahrzeug mehrere Meter mit im Zug selbst
wurde beim Abbremsen einer der Fahrgäste
verletzt
so jetzt noch Sport und zu Norbert König
und zu Frauenfußball Champions League
mit einer mittleren Enttäuschung für den
VfL Wolfsburg denn nach einer 2:0
Führung im Halbfinal-Hinspiel gegen den
FC Arsenal kassieren die
Wolfsburgerinnen noch zwei Gegentreffer
das Unentschieden keine tolle
Ausgangsposition fürs Rückspiel
Unzufriedenheit beim VfL Wolfsburg die
komfortable Führung durch Eva pajo und
dort hier hat nur bis kurz vor der
Halbzeit bestand
für den wieder starken englischen
Tabellen dritten der im Viertelfinale
Bayern München ausgeschaltet hat
verkürzt die Brasilianer in rafaele
Wolfsburg nicht konsequent genug
gleich in der zweiten Hälfte aus die
deutschen Meisterin nutzen ihre Chancen
nicht und Reisen nach dem 2:2 als
Außenseiterinnen zum Rückspiel am ersten
Mai in London
souverän ist 4:0 von Freiburg im gegen
Schalke im ersten Sonntagsspiel der
Fußball-Bundesliga die Breisgauer
zumindest vorübergehen darf Platz 3
Dortmund und München
Playoff Spiel Nummer 5 bringt die
Entscheidung der EHC München ist nach
dem 3:1 gegen Ingolstadt neuer deutscher
Meister im Eishockey der Männer es war
ein hartes Stück Arbeit für die Münchner
ehe ihr vierter Meistertitel feststand
Ingolstadt Macht zu wenig aus
Überzahlspiel die Münchner weitaus
effektiver das 2:1 durch Andreas Eder 8
Minuten vor Schluss bringt den EHC auf
die Siegerstraße Ingolstadt versucht
alles
Opfer den Torwart für einen weiteren
Feldspieler für warika ist das
freigeräumte Tor die Einladung zum 3:1
und damit zum vierten Sieg in der
Finalserie München nach 5 Jahren wieder
die deutsche Hochburg im Eishockey
Kevin kippt um rennt in London die zweit
schnellste Zeit in der Geschichte des
Marathonlaufs der 23 Jahre alte Kenianer
braucht zwei Stunden eine Minute und 25
Sekunden verfehlt den Weltrekord seines
Landsmannes Helios um 16 Sekunden in
ihrem ersten Marathonlauf überquert die
niederländische Olympiasiegerin Ziffern
Hassan als schnellste Frau die Ziellinie
vor dem Buckingham Palace die neue
Marathon Queen braucht zwei Stunden und
18 einhalb Minuten das ist auch ziemlich
flott
wir schauen schnell noch auf die
Wetteraussichten im Nordwesten und
Westen sind die Wolken meist dich und es
regnet auch mal länger sonst gibt's
Sonne und Wolken mit nur einzelnen
Schauern das ganze bei höchstens 9 bis
17 Grad
so das war es von uns mehr zur
Evakuierung der deutschen Staatsbürger
aus dem Sudan ab 21 Uhr im heute-journal
mit Marietta slom